if you oppose a death penalty because
you don't trust the government that's
one thing but if you oppose the death
penalty even if you knew the guy did it
you know for the purposes of Retribution
that's different because there are three
purposes of Criminal Justice deterrence
Rehabilitation and retribution well and
what's funny is the opponents of the
death penalty always downplay deterrence
they say it doesn't actually deter
people which is controversial but also
we don't really enforce the death
penalty anymore so it's like of course
it's not deterring people we don't
actually enforce it but then
Rehabilitation is when everyone focuses
on they say the only reason to punish
people is to rehabilitate them bring
them back into society obviously the
death penalty doesn't do that so I think
it actually does I think Dr Johnson is
right when he says depend upon it sir
when a man knows he's to be hanged in a
fortnight it concentrates his mind
wonderfully but furthermore the primary
purpose of the criminal justice system
up to and including capital punishment
but the whole thing it seems to me is
retribution